Congratulations and good job! You've made it to the end of Unit 1.
You've learned a lot about parallel computing on the GPU already,
both the fundamentals of the GPU programming model, and how to write your first GPU program.
Now we're going to talk to NVIDIA Chief Scientist and Senior Vice President of Research, Bill Dally.
Bill is one of the pioneers of parallel computing,
so I hope you enjoy his perspective as much as I do.
After the interview, we can dive into problem set 1,
where you'll write a program that will transform a color image into a gray scale image,
and we'll provide a lot of the surrounding code for this assignment,
but you're going to write the most important part;
the part that actually does the parallel processing on the GPU.